hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
the Fox News rundown the presidential
election is less than four months away
with presumptive Democratic nominee Joe
Biden's reported polling lead their
speculation President Trump could shake
up his campaign leadership former Trump
campaign manager now Trump 2020 campaign
senior adviser Corey Lewandowski weighs
in on this theory and discusses how the
re-election team plans to catch up in
key battleground states also Congress's
paycheck protection program facing
scrutiny yet again following revelations
country clubs and ventures backed by
billionaires benefited from coronavirus
relief loans Wall Street Journal
associate editor and Fox News
contributor John bussy shares his
thoughts on this controversy and the
likelihood of another stimulus plan plus
commentary from author and syndicated
columnist Cal Thomas the Fox News
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
FoxNews podcasts dot-com
I'm Martha McCallum I'm Bill Hemmer i'm
shannon bream and this is the fox news
rundown
[Music]
Wednesday July 8th 2020 I'm Dave Anthony
with Joe Biden leading in many polls
there's been speculation president Trump
could shake up his campaigns leadership
what I do you think you'll see some
change this campaign I think you'll see
some additions because the campaign is
about addition not subtraction it's
about adding more professional to the
organization so that you have surround
sound advocacy so that you have more
thought not left at Lisa Brady
the kovat surge around the country could
lead to another financial lifeline from
Washington then again it might not it
could be a more fractious debate with
the White House in Congress over what
needs to be done first deal with the
virus or just spend more money and I'm
Kel Thomas I've got the final word on
the fox news rundown
[Music]
as the coronavirus surges in many states
with record new US cases lately
President Trump has been pushing back
saying it's harmless to most people you
look at deaths are way down from this
horrible China virus and he wants
schools to reopen this fall everybody
wants it the moms wanted the dads wanted
the kids want it it's time to do it he's
focused a lot on the economic recovery
from the shutdowns that put us in a
recession the president has boasted of a
better third quarter which were in now
and an even better fourth quarter which
we will be in on election day in
November but many polls have him
trailing Joe Biden his Democratic
challenger it's so reminiscent to 2016
were at this point in the election cycle
most public polls showed that Hillary
Clinton had a nine-point advantage over
Donald Trump in national polling Corey
Lewandowski was the Trump campaign
manager for part of 2016
now back as a senior advisor in 2020 in
my opinion and I know something about
this stuff national polling doesn't
matter what does matter
other battleground states states like
Ohio and Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan
North Carolina Florida in a number of
those places Donald Trump isn't in as
good of a position if not a better
position at this point in the campaign
than he was in 2016 now I know it
doesn't fit the narrative but if you go
ask any reasonable Democrat if they
think that Joe Biden has a chance to win
in the state of Ohio there is no
reasonable person's going to say yes the
same is also true for Iowa we've taken
those states basically off the electoral
map which allows us to focus on the
additional battleground states very
important for our strategy for 2020
however there have been a lot of stories
that his electoral map is shrinking you
mentioned some of the states that you
think are good for the president Arizona
is a state that's said to be possibly
leaning toward Joe Biden North Carolina
Georgia's considered being play now
polls have shown Joe Biden in the lead
in Florida
some people think Texas is in play and
that Wisconsin and Michigan and
Pennsylvania all states the president
won in 2016 are
in jeopardy do you agree with that
analysis that has been out there lately
well I don't let me just tell you why
you know I keep hearing this now for 25
years that the Democrats have taken back
Texas the last time a Democrat won in
the state of Texas statewide now not
missing vital district but statewide was
before george w bush was elected
governor look North Carolina not only
did Mitt Romney carry that state when he
ran against Barack Obama Donald Trump
won that state it is a state that is a
huge military presence with Fort Bragg
there Camp Lejeune
it's a place where you know it has a big
military population and this president
has done enormous things for our men and
women who wear the uniform every day and
those that have retired so we saw
success in North Carolina as it relates
to Arizona absolute battleground state
we've got a competitive US Senate race
there but we've got a great team on the
ground there and we're going to win and
map also should indicate that states
like Minnesota all of a sudden have come
into play my home state of New Hampshire
where Donald Trump did not carry that
state by a tally of 2,700 votes is now
in play again for Donald Trump and he'll
be in New Hampshire on Saturday night so
we have opportunities in 2020 which we
didn't have in 2016 all right let's get
to the rally in New Hampshire it'll be
in Portsmouth it'll be outside there's
been more purging and recommending now
by the Trump campaign for people who go
to wear masks I think it's an issue of
personal responsibility
this is an outdoor rally in Portsmouth
New Hampshire it's going to take place
at 8 o'clock at night it's going to be
on an airport facility which means
airplane hangar some people will be in
some people will be out actually on the
runway or the tarmac as it's commonly
referred to there in the area so there's
plenty of room for social distancing if
people want to do that if people want
the precaution of wearing a mask
by all means they should do that people
need to have personal responsibility
here and that includes good sanitation
which is good hand-washing take care of
yourself if you have any symptoms we
don't want
you arriving if you are in a demographic
where you have the possibility of
becoming ill or you are more susceptible
to it we don't want to interacting with
other people and unlike the Tulsa rally
you know you're not going to see people
in a confined location in an indoor
arena so that's also going to help us
the virus has been surging in some of
these different a lot of states not New
Hampshire but a lot of other states like
Florida where the president's nomination
speech will be a lot of the convention
public events will be in Jacksonville
next month there's some concern about
that indoor space are you worried that
that might not happen the way
Republicans had hoped it would happen in
Jacksonville well I think the world of
coronavirus has changed everyone's
outlook on what things used to be and
where they are today I think we are in a
position where people are much more
cognizant of who they're interacting
with the handshaking the hugging all of
those things the close proximity to
other people look I believe that every
precaution should be taken and will be
necessary you know the Republican
National Committee is working very
diligently to make sure that before
people even arrive at the arena so
either at their hotels or on
transportation in everyone will be
tested for kovat 19 but I think we're
gonna have an amazing convention when
the president goes and accepts his
nomination from our party to be
reelected as a once again the 45th
president dates going back to 2016 in
June of that year the Trump campaign
made a change in Corey Lewandowski was
out as manager chairman Paul Manafort
took over in that in August
Kellyanne Conway now counselor to the
president became campaign manager in
2020
Brad Parr scale has that job there have
been reports at times the president or
others close to him have been unhappy
with par scale but he is still the
manager even after some personnel
changes you know III Scrabble with the
president of South Dakota to attend that
rally on the 3rd of July we didn't talk
about Brad at all but I do think you'll
see some changes at the campaign I think
you'll see some additions because the
campaign is about addition not
subtraction it's about adding more
professionals to the organization so
that you have surround sound
advocacy so that you have more thoughts
not less and I think what you continue
to seem you've started to see this
already at the campaign is the addition
of more people either in senior advisor
roles or people who are spending time
with the president and so I think that's
very very important you know I don't see
I don't foresee Brad going anywhere on
the campaign but I do think that Brad
recognizes the fact that more voices
coming in and giving more candid open
and honest discussion about ways that
the campaign should be moving forward is
very important and he has been very very
open to that me as a senior advisor you
know I have unlimited access to Brad I
participate in a series of very senior
calls where we discuss strategy and
ideas and objectives and so look he's
very open to that and I think you'll see
more of that as the campaign continues
here over the next four months Joe Biden
has long given President Trump an F for
his coronavirus response and the
presumed Democratic presidential nominee
calls him divisive amid all the racial
turmoil in the past few weeks Biden says
if he's elected he will transform the
country maybe change them to give them
marginalized and demonized the isolated
the oppressed a full share of the
American Dream that was in the former
vice president's fourth of July message
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created we've never
lived up to it Jefferson himself didn't
he held slaves women were excluded but
once proposed it was an idea
shouldn't be constrained a statue of
Thomas Jefferson is among those torn
down the past two weeks President Trump
is called those protesters anarchists
and his fourth of July weekend message
was different we will never allow an
angry mob to tear down our statues erase
our history indoctrinate our children or
trample on our freedoms he keeps calling
for law and order when it comes to the
right to protest
nobody is opposed to that there is a
proper way to do that
there are traditionally permits that are
issued for these things and large
gatherings have happened in our country
since the Boston Tea Party but this
notion that people can just go and take
the protest into their own hands and
destroy federal pieces of property is
not one that our country supports and
you know the people who are most
insulted by this by and large of the
women the suburban women who want the
safety and security for their family and
that's what the president standing up
for the people who believe that it is
their right to be able to walk down the
street and not have to live in fear to
know that they have a business that will
not be destroyed because someone is
protesting over something and this
notion that we're tearing down statues
now of people like Abraham Lincoln
someone who obviously freed the slaves I
think what we have is a small group of
people who don't understand their
history who are doing this just to
destroy property and the president is
going to stand with the law and order
people of this country a hundred percent
of the time where do you think Joe Biden
is most vulnerable as we get into the
fall we have the debates of course what
do you think the president is going to
go after most well look I think it's
very clear that in Joe Biden's 44 years
in elective office in Washington DC he
doesn't have a signature piece of
legislation that he can talk about
because the one piece of legislation
that he did champion which was the
criminal justice package
disproportionately impacted African
American men by putting them in jail for
a longer period of time than anybody
else and Joe doesn't want to talk about
that Joe doesn't want to talk about the
fact that he gave the eulogy at Robert
Byrd's funeral a member of the Klu Klux
Klan Joe doesn't want to talk about the
fact that his mentor when he went into
the USN
1973 with senator eastland of
Mississippi who was known as the voice
of the white South Joe doesn't want to
talk about his racist past but that's
okay that's okay because the American
people have seen what Donald Trump has
been able to do for the african-american
community and minority communities
whether it's empowerment zones whether
it is the lowest unemployment rate ever
recorded in in the african-american
community our Hispanic community whether
it is criminal justice reform you know
Donald Trump is completely agnostic to
the color of a person's skin and Joe
Biden can't say the same in his
legislative record is one that clearly
indicates he has not supported the
african-american community in his 44
years in public service and that needs
to be reminded to some people there are
a lot of people that call the
president's and even some elected
officials call the president a racist or
a white supremacist it's such an easy
thing to do right it's so easy to throw
terms around to say things like you're
racist or you're a misogynist or you're
xenophobic but his record is very
different Barack Obama had the
opportunity in eight years to do all of
the things that President Trump has been
able to do in the first three years
whether that's criminal justice reform
whether it's the empowerment zones
whether it is commuting a number of
individuals or pardoning individuals who
are wrongfully in prison for what was at
the time very minor crimes I think of
Alice Johnson who was serving a life
sentence for drug trafficking and Donald
Trump freed her not Barack Obama do you
think Democrats are overconfident well
aren't they always you know it's always
amazing you know I do think that the
truth is they've got a good Senate map
this cycle is the converse of what we
had two years ago so they may have some
opportunities to pick up some seats in
the United States Senate but they always
overplay their hands but they don't
represent the values of the American
people which is law and order smaller
government lower taxes less regulation
and being proud to be Americans and it's
sad to say that the Democratic Party no
longer holds those ideals to be
important but it is something that is
truthful corey lewandowski
good to talk to you again thank you very
much for joining us thank you my
pleasure
[Music]
this is Cal Thomas with your FoxNews
commentary
coming up many businesses especially
small businesses were hoping for a
summer of recovery but coronavirus
doesn't care
Texas chopping 10,000 cases in a single
day California also hitting a new daily
record and hospitals and over two dozen
Florida counties reaching full capacity
in intensive care units President Trump
says what's not being reported is a
decline in the u.s. mortality rate in
that his response has saved millions of
lives as the administration focuses on
reopening not reclosing there is a safe
way to reopen the economy and we're
going to do that carefully
that was Treasury secretary Steve
minutia after Thursday's employment
report for June showing a second
straight month of job gains and he often
praises the popular paycheck protection
program intended for small businesses
though some not so small operations
ended up getting loans some of them
returning the money later even bans
tapping into the flow because of
canceled or postponed tours big names
like the Eagles and Pearl Jam the
program initially approved just a few
weeks after shutdowns began in March 1
over whelming support in Congress the
presumption was well shut down it's
gonna be a few weeks maybe a couple of
months john bussy is an associate editor
of The Wall Street Journal and a Fox
News contributor and if we keep as many
small businesses the same to small
businesses thriving and able to keep
people on their payroll and able to pay
their grants and pay you know for food
that that would be a way also of
sustaining the economy but what happens
with these these kinds of programs
particularly when the restrictions on
them are kind of unclear is that you
have you have everybody belly up to the
trough and in this case a lot of big
companies big law firms big hedge funds
big real estate companies you know the
the personal businesses of some Congress
people everybody kind of rushed the door
they weren't sure how long the crisis
was going to last and there was you know
essential
free cash at hand this was money that if
you if you've met certain minimal
criteria you kept people on the payroll
eventually it would become a grant so
people went for it and as a result a
disproportionate amount of the money get
ended up going to larger entities not
necessarily any small business but
bigger companies there's also been
people with ties to political leaders
who are among the loan recipients a
company that Jared Kushner used to own a
company that has speaker Pelosi's
husband invested in you know how does
that make the small business owner who
doesn't have those connections feel
trampled I would imagine you know the
the lawyer and the law firm rather the
law firm of that represented helped
represent President Trump during the
Moller investigation and did work for
him before he became president this was
one of the entities that got a PPP loan
as well as a lot of other law firms you
know sometimes these are partners who
are earning north of a million dollars
apiece that's not small business in the
traditional sense of what the average
American would think of his small
business you know the local diner the
local nail salon the barber the dry
cleaner you know this small grocery
store you know in your neighborhood so a
lot of the money ended up sort of going
to bigger entities you could argue that
that had a positive impact because it
did help people stay employed but the
larger entities were meant to have other
means of getting cash this program was
for those companies who didn't have
ready access to a revolving line of
credit at a bank or to shareholders or
to you know other entities that could
kick in cash to keep them going this was
meant to be a lifeline to those small
businesses that recent surge that we're
having around the country to raises more
questions because what happens now that
some businesses are having to close a
second time for instance in Florida
where they're telling bars to shut back
down again
if those workers are furloughed a second
time how does that affect the existing
loan
including you know the rules for having
the loan be forgiven look the the
unfortunate mismanagement of the health
crisis the fact that we have no national
plan we don't have national testing and
and contact tracing and isolation
programs it's all left up to this to the
state in this kind of cacophony of
different programs some are opening
their schools some are not some are
providing data some are not and you have
this surge of cases leaves you to the
conclusion that one that will have to be
additional stimulus Congress has already
been active on that front but that this
is going to damage the very businesses
that the PPP program were meant was
what's meant to save those those small
businesses if they have to close again
and some are already having to close are
going to get crushed by this they're
gonna fight they're gonna have to not
just furlough but layoff people and the
funds that are forthcoming the next time
may simply not be enough to keep them
going the House passed another relief
bill in May the heroes Act but unlike
the previous cares Act it passed mainly
along party lines and the three trillion
dollar effort stalled in the Senate
where Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
has been leading a Republican
wait-and-see approach to further
stimulus efforts even he's now signaling
it may be time we may well do that and
if we do it we'll do it in July and I
can tell you for sure that if we do
another bill it will have liability
protections in it but that's one of
several ideas that does not appear to
have much bipartisan support after the
may unemployment report proved fairly
positive and after there was this uptick
in economic activity of the United
States as cases were trending down in
particularly hard-hit states like New
Jersey in New York there was a bit of
optimism on the Republican side and in
the White House in kind of wandering
cheese do we need to really spend as
much as the Congress is asking us to
spend on another round well that was
that was before what's happened to Texas
and Florida and Arizona and Oklahoma and
California where there's been a
resurgence of the coronavirus it never
went away now the debate is going to be
over okay well how much do we need to
spend to keep these companies afloat and
will that actually be enough if there's
no end in sight if we haven't somehow
found a way to vanquish or at a minimum
tame the virus are we going to be
constantly having to re-up trillions and
trillions more to keep the cut as the
economy stimulated I think that the
conclusions going to come around -
you've got to do a better job of
managing containment of the virus before
you can even begin to think of any end
to stimulating the economy I've
definitely heard Democrats make the
argument that there hasn't been enough
you know national leadership on this but
on the other hand do things like the
problems with the paycheck protection
program and even the problems at the
state level with the unemployment
insurance system and big delays for some
people in getting those checks in the
first place
do those kind of problems you know run
counter to the traditional Democratic
push for more and bigger government
running things because it doesn't always
work out so well
that's right whenever you push this
money much money out the door as quickly
as it was pushed you're gonna have lots
of problems that we're seeing that right
now the argument that will be made is
yes that's true but it was it was a fire
extinguisher on a blazing fire and it
needed to happen fast it needed to
happen in an expansive way that doesn't
really make you feel too satisfied as a
taxpayer though when you're seeing large
multi you know million dollar entities
get this money and even Lisa groups that
are against big business the Ayn Rand
Institute you know whose founder was not
a not not fond of big a big government
rather of government sort of a dead hand
of
being involved with business seek out
these funds and so there's there's a lot
of irony in this and there's a lot of
waste and there's a lot of misdirection
of the money all that said I think the
argument against doing nothing is that
you would have had a much worse
circumstance for individuals who did
need to pay their rent and companies who
have been able to at a minimum keep the
lights on and sustain themselves through
the last four months but the coming
months are a whole different story it
could be a it could be a more fractious
debate with the White House in Congress
over what needs to be done first deal
with the virus or just spend more money
in the midst of all of this President
Trump is following through on his threat
to withdraw from the World Health
Organization which he's criticized along
with China for the response to the
initial coronavirus outbreak in Wuhan
are you seeing any evidence that this is
something the American public is paying
attention to at all or is you know
worried about the virus really just
swallowing everything else well I think
it's probably the latter people are most
interested in their day to day life and
whether or not their kids are gonna be
able to go back to school and the fall
whether it's safe for them whether
they've got a job whether it's safe to
go back to that job get on the subway
get to work what's going to be happening
at work you know if I'm X you know age
am I going to be exposing myself to the
Cova
you know at work and the WHI way off in
Geneva is kind of not on their radar
screen the president's decision to
withdraw the United States is a result
of his feeling that the w-h-o
misinformed the United States about the
severity of the outbreak in China he
blames China for the same not inform in
the United States
he believes blames the w-h-o he blames
individual state governors particularly
in democratic states for not doing
enough about the corona virus there's a
lot of blaming done by
the president but the truth of the
matter is that he was getting plenty of
intelligence separate from the w-h-o
through the National Security Council
and other health authorities you know
way back at the beginning of the year
and the president delayed you know
talked the virus down said that it was
going away said it would go away heating
in the spring you know got warm
I mean you've you've heard heard all
this so the blame the whu-oh I think is
kind of a non-starter it serves a
purpose it's not perfect but it serves a
purpose and it's in the health interest
and in the self-interest of the United
States citizen to be a part of that
internet national organization we've
essentially given them a a one-year
notice of withdrawal so it'll be
interesting to see what happens with
that john bussy Fox News contributor and
associate editor of The Wall Street
Journal thanks very much for your time
my pleasure
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from Fox News for Amazon
Alexa Jessie Alexa plain news from Fox
in Fox News it's the latest when you
need it on demand from Fox News and
Amazon Alexa Raiden review the Fox news
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary what's on your mind what did
we think what happened once boundaries
were destroyed the chaos plaguing the
country today was inevitable after truth
standards and self-control were all but
ignored by many in our society that
great philosopher the late Marilyn
Monroe was ahead of her time when she
said quote when I was five I think
that's when I started wanting to be an
actress I love to play I didn't like the
world around me because it was kind of
grim but I loved to play house it was
like you can make your own boundaries
unquote making one's own boundaries has
led us to this moment
truth has become subjective the US
Constitution some judges claim is now
open to interpretation as we witness win
a Supreme Court majority six to three
again
legislated from the bench when they
redefine sex in the 1964 Civil Rights
Act as meaning not simply gender as in
male and female but sexual identity as
in gay and transgender after the courts
2015 ruling in favor of same-sex
marriage it was five to four polygamous
group said they'd be next to demand
equal treatment what's to stop them
what if morals and laws evolve and
conformity to the spirit of the age and
opinion Falls is what matters most
statues and paintings that offends some
but not others are being torn down or
defaced perhaps the frieze over the US
Supreme Court building should also be
removed it shows many law givers looking
to Moses who is at the center holding
the Ten Commandments those are no longer
considered relevant in today's America
so maybe they should be chiseled away
church-state separation you know In God
We Trust is embedded on walls and the
House and Senate and on our money
clearly that's no longer objectively
true so
perhaps we should remove that saying
hearings could be held so people who
claim we continue to trust in God can
present evidence we still do
valedictorians sports trophies and in
some cases grades have been abandoned
because some who were not as talented or
didn't work as hard to achieve honor
might feel bad
so we dumbed down and make everyone
equal
supporting mediocrity as the highest
objective this is what socialism does
those who deny any standard and then
appeal to the rest of us based on a
standard of their own making can't have
it both ways though they're trying the
lead evangelist and scholar Ravi
Zacharias observed quote pleasure
without God without the sacred
boundaries will actually leave you empty
er than before and this is biblical
truth this is experiential truth the
loneliest people in the world are
amongst the wealthiest and most famous
who found no boundaries within which to
live
that is a fact I've seen again and again
unquote as the psalmist wrote long ago
when the foundations are being destroyed
what can the righteous do I'm Cal Thomas
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
[Music]
it's the Perino and steyr Walt I'll tell
you what podcast Dana Perino of the five
and Fox News political editor Christina
all dissect the ins and outs of national
politics subscribed and listen now by
going to fox news podcasts dot job love
fox news click the subscribe button to
get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes